Hey, how's it going, bros my name
is PEWWWDIEPIE
I'm playing kitty cat jigsaw puzzles
But I'm not here to talk about the game play
Even though it does get pretty sick later on..
You get a nuke at the end
I'm currently sick so I apologize for the lack of facecam. (no face cam....)
But that's okay
I wanted to make this video anyway
there's a lot of you have been
commenting saying that my content has
been getting better lately
I wanted to give you guys my warmest way
of saying..
don't get used to it! xD
if you're new here you should know that
my content will always be garbage and my
jokes will always be cringe-worthy
thank you very much though but yeah my
channel had a bit of a second wind over
the summer
if you look at the graph here my views
have been going down for the longest time
despite many efforts and the only reason
anyone is probably still watching is
because my ego is now so massive that I
call people out on shit that I even do
myself I'm probably the biggest
hypocrite on youtube but at the same time
at least i'm aware of all this
you could say I finally became
self-aware and that's when my content
started to become less garbage can see
it here on the graph to be fair though I
owe a massive thanks to Michael and Brad
for helping me out with videos lately
you've probably seen them in some of my
videos i had for the longest time the
approach to youtube that I had to do
everything by myself and I would say
this a lot but I see now how absolutely
depressing that was for four years this
sitting alone by myself in front of a
computer every single day
it's just.. it's just fucking sad! (':
I honestly can't remember having any
interests or liking anything else but
youtube at the time and I think if you
ask me I probably would have just said:
"youtube" but my biggest thanks I owe to
you bros for watching my videos over the years
I know I make a lot of dumb jokes and I
know it might seem like I don't care but
I.. really do
and it means the world that you bros are
watching my videos so thank you! AAWNNNN :P
now i don't know if my views will keep
growing from this . although we all know
it's all about the watch time now but i
do know that I'm finally enjoying making
videos every single day and I think that
shows in my content
I feel like I'm back again we are now at
47 million subscribers which is probably
the dumbest number i could possibly
think of (how can a number be dumb?)
but I do appreciate every single one of
you and thank you for watching this has
been
kitty cat jigsaw gameplay I realized I
finish this video seven minutes too
early and most youtubers were probably
just ramble on for this time . but I am
just going to keep the gameplay going
for the remainder as an attempt of an
ironic joke that I'm still very much
profiting off of
thank you so much for watching and as
always stay awesome bros
*bruhfist* *Wait For The Subtitles...*
Here They  Come!!
Not Much Longer Now!!!
Ahh. The music.
....
So why are you still here?
That's great queen
IS THE PHANDOM HERE? Just wanted to know. (no leafy is here.)
The phandom is EVERYWHERE
quality cotntent right here buddy.
Aww thats a cute kitty ^_^
And it's gone...
fml
ummmm.
me and that kitten had something ;-;
So seriously, why are you watching? For the subtitles? Or the gameplay?     subtitles ofc
Or for the pure fact that Pewds profits off of it.
Awww. That's sweet of you.
You must have better things to do than watch a grown man without comentary play a puzzle game with music in the background.
yeh we watch the subtitles
Awww look at the kitty's face
Anyone have any kittens out there?
Anyone have a kitten named mitten?
IT RHYMES  IM A RAPPER NOW MAMMA TEEEEHEEEELOL
Remember, it's ZoMu or NoMu. ~ZoMu Leedle
I'm a dog person
*Waits for the Kitten Fandom to come after me*
Aww the kitten though I don't under stand why I love it.
Animals are cute Period.
.... I wonder how long I'm going to put subtitles in...
I'm just doing this to keep the content intresting so Pewds can get some watch time cause I'm generous.
NEXT PUZZLE!!!
Kittens. Kittens. Kittens.
Its seriously 2AM and I'm writing subtitles on a Pewdiepie video. Great. I have a life.
#dixsoutforhambre
*puzzle intensifies
This music is FIRE.
Name something that's FIRE and I'll guess it.
RiceGum
Nope? Okay.. Dan's Roast Urself Challenge
#WhoKnewDanCouldRap
Get that trending right now
Five minutes in and you are still watching this video
I'm gonna leave now. Can someone take over? Good Night.
Ugh I dont think I can I have no life.
Whos watched Suicide Squad?
Kewl
WTF it doesn't go there...
Look how adorable that kitten is!!!
Honestly you should go to the UK subtitles they are g8 m8.
I'm probably going to watch this video in every language lol
LACK OF MUSIC
There it is...
BEAT DROP WAS FIRE AF.
Go back to 0:13 you can hear him whisper "Help Me."
Sorry that was offensive.
Marinia fans plz dont kill me
I cant get over the music its so fireeee.
*prepare for un funny pun*
THIS KITTENS ON FIREEEEE!
Just kidding.
Next puzzle biatch!!
Srsly how long did Pewds play this WTF.
Wouldnt you get bored?
I'd get bored.
YOU CAN WEAR MY SWEATSHIRT
Any Jacob fans out there? (No)
#JacobSavedMe
Erm but seriously WHO LIKES JACOB SAGGYTITTIES.
8 Year Olds...
Ugh he's 13 I feel bad now...
I bet he's sweet....
No I bet hes an asshole... NEW TOPIC
The fact that your still watching this video is amazing.
Like seriously do you have no life?
None?
Me neither
We're the same!!!
.......
Our bonding moment...
Erm 4 more minutes to go!!!
Don't worry it gets worse...
So. Any AHS fans out there?
EVAN PETERS <3
*crumbles to the grounds*
Does anyone do that in real life?
duh every one does
Like say "Falls over and cracks open forehead" cause I do. And it's quite annoying I'll admit it.
Still confused?
I get that alot. (Me too)
anyone back to school? (Me Ou0!)
I am. Schools great.
Homework.
Science
Writing.
Math
Maybe school isnt that fun.
I should drop out. (Dont snort, matter fact dont breathe)
*Drops out of 7th grade*
That moment when you realize the girl writing the subtitles is a twelve year old.
Awww that kitten!
This video has ruined my future
I will become a crazy cat lady in the future.
Or a stripper.
One of the two
#savefelix #savehim #saveeveryone #hashtagsforfelicity #felix*
bro fissssssssssssssssssssssst (me felix)
All around me are familiar faces
Worn out places
worn out faces
I eat breakfast
TRIGGERED
I take a walk
I catch a Charizard
I GOTS TAH CATCH DA POKEYMONS
Why are you still here
Get a life.
Says the little girl writing subtiles at 3 AM on a Pewdiepie video.
Ugh.
TRIGGERED
These Kittens are triggering me
So hows life
Lyfe is shyte :c
Kool
lol kool? srsly?
Life is...
Strange.
TRIGGGERRRED
Eight minutes in and your still watching
Dedication
...
No it's honestly just stupid do something useful.
Literally ME!
LITERALLY MY LIFE IS..
I dont know the rest of the words
Ava fans dont kill me
I just suck at life.
I love how any time a video doesnt have commentary the community fixes that lol
Pewds should become a professional kitten puzzle solver.
oh hey this space is empty let me fill it... i have no life
Whop 2 more minutes of kittens.
So many kittens, im going to die.
AHH. IM BACK AND I GOT BORED SO I CAME BACK HERE TO FINISH WRITING THE SUBTITLES....
I'm a loser.
Sooo opinions on the 100 Layers of Cum video???
When Leafy made the video.... That's when Trish knew she fucked up.
#RemoveTrishaPaytas
Idk I feel like there's worse... There's ten minute videos of people playing kittycat jigsaw without commentary.
Oh shit
*47 million people attack me*
Just kidding I love Pewds. Just had to clarify for the easily triggered.
I can't say shit I get triggered by waking up in the morning
I get triggered by shoes
Triggered by music
Triggered by YouTube
Triggered by cats
Everything in this video makes me want to drink alot of beach
Im more triggered than when I first heard "Sweatshirt"
*Moves the topic from Jacob Sartorius again*
Iron nugget
I stay away from the controversy that is musical.ly.
I use musical.ly but I'm not like a typical 12 year old..
I don't wake up every morning and strive to be a famous LIP SINGER WTF?
UGHHH.
WHAT IS THIS WORLD
WHY IS MUSICAL.LY SIMPLE YET CANCEROUS AS FUCK
why
Sorry I'm a CRY BABY ;)
Im sorry I'm never winking again..
;)
OMG PEWDS. WHY. DID YOU DO THIS FOR SOOOO LONG WTF
obviously it goes there up pewds
Or... not...
..... I'm twelve giving a 26 year old man help in a puzzle through a video that's already made
TRIGGERED
*sigh* PAPAPAPAPA PLAY THAT SHEIT!!
Leafy fans where u at???
......
*sigh*
carefully move the piece in to position now
carefully....
there you go
The cats trigger me
TRIGGERED SO HARD BY THESE CATS
fuck my life.
Here's some cat rp:
*Cat 1*  hey, what's this red button do?
*Cat 2* I dunno
*Cat 1* Imma touch it
*Cat 2* no pls no
*Cat 1* but I--
*Cat 2* stop it right meow
*Cat 1* but--
*Cat 1* >:3
Ugh here's the end ;-; ur leaving me... I thought we had a connection
why has god abandoned us
oh shet wtf
rando: Deez nuts
BYE MOM, KITTENS AND EARTH *hoomangus beeg xplosin*
*fades out*
rando: oooh cool, im at the end!
Me too lol